in five we're gonna write into it five
four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
I am your pastor David so many blessings
to you I hope all of you out there have
been going to church if not just know
you're going to [ __ ] hell you piece
of [ __ ] trash honestly could care
less about you you stupid sons of
[ __ ] yeah that's a that's Korean
Church [ __ ] so we have a very special
guest today we got destiny Rogers you so
you so what's the card you're so hip you
know what somebody said to me so
somebody said to me I look like a
[ __ ] Korean train conductor dude
stupid son of a [ __ ] that should hurt
my feelings cause it was accurate
we have destiny Rogers yeah musician
skateboarder extraordinaire and to be
honest to you I was just put onto your
music recently okay because of these men
right here they're not on camera right
now but management producers you guys
will bring them on another podcast but
it's not about them right now it's about
you so destiny and I'm pretty sure
people already know who you are out
there like I'm just saying it just
because a few people don't know people
people [ __ ] know who you are man
people are gonna ask like how did you
get destiny on here I was like I [ __ ]
gave her like three lollipops she's 19
years old I did magic tricks for her but
yeah how did you get started in music
let's just ask the questions I got
started in music from church really yep
from church yeah yeah my dad he was he's
a worship leader so yeah Corner raised
in church like my whole life I started
playing like for worship on Sundays when
I was 10 years old oh you got those
classic Christian core no most
definitely yes are you from first off
I'm from Lodi California oh that place
sucks but if you're from Lodi you
already know what I'm talking about you
know how [ __ ] there's nothing to do
in Lodi nothing it's a farm town farm
town vineyards wine cows that's so
interesting because like when I when I
picture Lodi cuz I'm for a second
right so I picture loaded I just I
literally picture wine country and
[ __ ] nothing out there like I don't
really see kids walking around you see a
bunch of old people so what what what
town are you from in within Lodi like is
there I guess I would say like I'm from
like the north side the north side part
of that I like I don't even how to
explain it like it's so small we don't
even really have sections that mean
really yeah that's so interesting cuz
like when I when I when I first of all
just hearing your music and kind of just
I just don't picture you being a part of
a small town right just because of like
your music and how you sing so how did
who are your influences like how did you
even get started just because I feel
like well I guess because the Internet
right like you get to listen to hear
everything yeah yeah it was definitely
from YouTube like I got started getting
into music when I was a sixth-grade cuz
Justin Bieber was like he was my first
now he was my first inspiration when it
came first crush probably huh you
[ __ ] sick little [ __ ] he's actually
the first youtuber that popped off
people don't even know that yeah no yeah
he was the first at least for me I know
he's the first youtuber he's be so cute
he had a little lesbian haircut and
everything I thought he was tight man he
was dope and I loved him and he was I
heard some weird stories about Justin
Bieber like weird stories I'm gonna say
it on this podcast I could give a [ __ ]
less but I heard this [ __ ] funny a
story about him where so I had a friend
who used to work for a company that did
like artists travel visas and stuff and
you know justin bieber is like on all
this like religious [ __ ] so mind you
this isn't my story this is a story that
I heard from somebody that I know so and
I'm gonna soil his [ __ ] name but
anyways Justin Bieber used to do this
[ __ ] where you know a lot of male
artists they like to [ __ ] around with
women so he would do this thing where he
was on this religious tip right so he
would always say like God first got
everything you know like a lot of
artists do I'm saying that he really
does but he would make a lot of these
like artist visa from what I heard sit
and wait because people just need him to
sign some papers just so they could get
the visa done but then she told me that
she would witness him going upstairs
with a random
and he would start reading Bible verses
to her since like before they would [ __ ]
so he would say [ __ ] like hey I just
want to tell you that I'm reformed and I
love Jesus Christ and I need to know
that Jesus Christ is your Savior as well
and she would be like yes and then he
goes cool let's [ __ ] like I'm [ __ ]
serious but the [ __ ] was that he would
make her wait downstairs for like three
or four hours and he wouldn't sign the
papers until he was ready to do it
so that's [ __ ] crazy right [ __ ] you
Justin Bieber shoutout see that's the
thing about my career I don't care about
it that's the that's the wild [ __ ] so
you grew up in Lodi yeah and you grew up
in a Christian household I did so it is
your father's or are they still praise
leaders and stuff - yeah my dad my dad's
worship leader my hometown yeah yeah
he's still doing it so he must be like
super proud of you then right oh yeah
most music yeah most definitely
I'm not sure if you understand I was
just having a conversation with like
John about this about like do you
understand by the trajectory that you're
on because a lot of people because
you're 19 right as a 19 year old for you
to be able to be on this type of
trajectory towards music to have some of
the biggest people in this industry
shout you out is unreal like when he was
telling me the people that were shot in
you what I was shocked yeah I'm shocked
too still I mean who okay so for you as
a musician who your biggest influences
biggest influences kehlani Billy Eilish
and she [ __ ] hit you were both best
[ __ ] crazy did you cry uh I didn't
cry it was just like I was just really I
was like shaking and like my heart was
beating and like I was sweating and like
it was crazy I wasn't crying though did
you get to meet them yet I got to meet
Billy but I haven't met Caitlyn yet but
I've seen her perform before what was it
like meeting her Billy
super dope super dope I actually met her
at her like her album experience party
when her album dropped so I got to go to
that and then she didn't know I was
coming so when I seen her I was like
kind of a like kind of afraid to go up
to her still even though like she knew
who I was and stuff so like it wasn't
like I was a complete stranger just
going up to her but um I was just like
yeah like Emerson
just gonna go up there so as I was
walking up she see me and she like was
like
oh my god is she like open horizon
gaming she was like I can love you bro
she was like tomboy soul fire and then
and then I ended up meeting her manager
after her manner her manager was like so
your destiny you're the one bill he's
been ranting to me about and I'm like oh
word he goes yeah like look at my phone
he pulls up text messages of her telling
him like oh listen to this girl she's
about to blow up and like sent a
screenshot of tomboy to him
that's [ __ ] yeah so he's like she's
like ranting to like her manager about
me which is that's a pretty [ __ ] big
deal he's not a single celebrity has
nothing about me at all
I've been doing it for a long time most
people if I could hate my guts that's so
great yeah so what about so how did
Kaline hit you up kailani I don't know
how but it was I was literally at my
apartment tanning at my pool and um a
friend of mine hit me and was like yo I
know you're freaking out right now and I
was like what do you mean and she sent
me a screenshot of Kay Lonnie's
Instagram story with tomboy on it saying
that it was a fire record and then I was
like wait I did not see this yet so I
went on Instagram and looked for myself
and I was like holy crap she did that
and so and she didn't follow me on
Instagram but I ended up tweeting it and
I'm like oh my god Ken Loney see my
story or see my or her my song and
posted on her story and so instantly
like two minutes within me tweeting that
she retweeted it quoted it and said I
love that song girl like keep it up did
it up and then she then she followed me
on Instagram and then she damned me
that's [ __ ] crazy Ben Nye was like
best friends and [ __ ] I wish no that's
not how you do it so you gotta learn how
to work this [ __ ] you guys you gotta
work this you guys are best [ __ ]
friends everybody doesn't an industry
that like you know yeah yeah that's my
girl yeah that's my girl
[ __ ] she made me a cake I ate it I
was like it's all right be sure recipes
I [ __ ] took a slice out is what it is
that's tight so so what's up next for
you hopefully the possible tour more
music I've been in the studio working
creating making more music [ __ ] more
show little girl just [ __ ] talking
like a goddamn adult I am [ __ ] pisses me
off so bad when I was 19 yo I didn't fit
in
I don't even sound like this when you
guys met me bro I don't even sound like
this when I was 23 like what the [ __ ]
that's crazy you look like a grown-ass
woman that's so [ __ ] annoying yeah I
gotta get my calendar out I got to make
sure that if I could dream my alkaline
water oh my god damn dude how did how
did this happen
how did you guys get connected so this
happened it all originated from a friend
of my from Lodi from church he was a
drummer for our worship team he moved to
LA to be a producer and in the meantime
he got an internship at the stereotype
studio so this was in 2017 so I was 17
at the time and at that time I was still
living in Lodi but I was like just I was
independent so like I was posting my own
music and like just figuring out ways
like to promote myself like by myself so
at that time I was just posting YouTube
covers so I posted a collied location
and cover with the mashup of Drake fake
love and get you by Daniel Cesar I
posted it on YouTube and a friend of
mine Zach his name's Zach he was like a
destiny like I'm gonna show your video
to like one of my friends like he works
he just did that's they just did that's
what I liked by Bruno Mars and I was
like oh dope because I was my favorite
record I'm like yeah like show them show
them the Sun yeah so show them whatever
and so um like I thought time I really
wasn't stoked about it just because I
was just like so in my own zone like
working on my own stuff I was like I
don't want anybody interfering like I
don't wanna I don't want any like that
so like I was that [ __ ] [ __ ] Johnny
Jeremy I said [ __ ] she's just like meta
[ __ ] these people do they don't know me
I'm destiny not it was I was just like
in my own world and I was like yeah go
ahead like it doesn't hurt do it and so
um he ended up showing them the video
and they loved it and they're like you
know like can we set up a meeting with
her like we want to meet her and so um
is that got in contact with my mom and
then he was like hey grace uh some of my
guys want to meet destiny their names a
stereotype so my mom was like okay well
my mom was hesitant to so my mom was
like okay well we have to do our
research and like just see if these guys
are really rude and so like like I have
hella ants I have like four ants that
are like like my mom's sisters like
they're super like in my career too so
they're late they just want to know
everything
doing so we all of us did the research
and like they're like yeah like I think
I think it'd be good like for destiny to
meet them and so I was there all right
let's go so they're like I think I go a
week later I went to their studio and I
had my guitar in my hand and I'm walking
down the hall and I see like plaques on
the walls and I'm just like all right
yeah they furro furro I was like you're
officially the first people you thought
were trash Oh walked in the studio
you're like oh [ __ ] these are somebody
nah I knew it like when I looked him up
I knew they did like Far East Movement
stuff and like they did Justin Bieber
and all that and obviously Bruno so I
was just like all right like they for
real like let's just go meet them and
shake hands and get my name you know get
my name out but um anyways once our
studio walked in there's like hello guys
in there I'm like yo with something
that's new yeah and they're just like
we're just talking like a normal
conversation and like they asked me to
sing so I sang for them and then um was
that [ __ ] nerve wrecking though no no
like I was just I'm just oh I always
sing for people so it's just like
they're just like hey can you sing this
some night so I think that's the
probably one of the big differences that
you have compared to other people right
so yeah cuz a lot of people would be
nervous in those type of situations like
even if you sang your whole [ __ ] life
right even though that's who you are and
what you're about sometimes when people
are up to bat
they can't [ __ ] bad because people
get scared man I'll give you a great
example when I was a when I wasn't not
for me not for me but when I was in I
did this panel at San Diego there's this
kid now he stood up and when this kid
stood up he was like oh it was basically
Q&A and he was asking me now somebody
who wanted to be a musician know he went
to UCSD so he asked me he goes hey so
what do you feel about like you know
Asian kids and whatever and their
parents not letting them pursue what
they want to do and I was like what what
do you want to do right he goes oh I
wanna be a singer it's like cool man
there's like 800 people here you could
come up right now come up and sing
kid says no even with a big opportunity
like that I mean it's not huge but it's
a crowd full of 800 people and he wants
to be a singer about the balls nope you
say yep come up here and sing and I was
like yeah well we'll grab a guitar from
somewhere or some [ __ ] or keys and let's
let's get you to sing kick clammed up
because no I can't do it like I don't
want to do it I was like well that's the
difference yeah I mean you don't you
don't want it that bad which is kind of
cool that you
mean you kind of understood who you were
in front of and you just saying like it
was nothing yeah you don't get nervous
at all no I don't like any every
meetings like any meeting that I've had
like I've never really been nervous it's
just like all right I'm using alright
for sure
I'm just gonna say wow that's so [ __ ]
crazy I can't even match cuz there's a
19 year old I can't put myself in that
[ __ ] good at a 19 year olds very high
for me personally I was a very unsure
kid I don't know what I wanted I mean I
did stand up as a kid but I don't know
but let's say if I was a kid that was
doing stand-up right and then somebody
like Dave Chappelle was like i'ma come
and see your set I would [ __ ] myself I
would [ __ ] [ __ ] myself
that's insane so what happened after
that literally the same night there it
is I go destiny like do you wanna we
want to work with you like can we work
to you for a full week and at that time
it was my senior year of high school so
like I had like two weeks left no I had
like about a month left of my senior
year before I graduated and so I was
like okay like I definitely don't wanna
go to college was like my teachers were
like college college college and I'm
like there's no way I don't want to go I
was like I know what I want I want to
see the world you know and so I was like
I can't tour and see the world by going
to school like there's no way it's not
gonna get me there so at that time I was
like yeah let's do it
so it was my like so we ended up getting
in about like I think like two weeks
later or something and ended up working
with them for a full week was my first
time ever working in like a professional
studio like they had like co-writers
that came in and they're like hey so I
was gonna write a song with you today
I'm like what do you mean cuz I would
always write my own stuff by myself and
produce my own music myself so like I
ever get you dude I've never [ __ ]
it's so inspiring bro and it's [ __ ]
annoying at the same time because it
says I'm like comparing my own life
story to this right I was like 19 what
the [ __ ] was I doing I got dumped
it's like 280 pounds [ __ ] pimples
that's about right nah but um but yeah
ended up just working them for a week
and then then they like called me back
and they're like yeah do you want to
work again next month and I was like
yeah I was like let's do it my aunt
lives in LA so like when I'd come down
I'd sneak her so I'm so you got fed me
oh that's dope just just my aunt and my
uncle in 2000
but I suggest this like yes my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
about but um be out like it became like
an every month thing like I graduated
high school and then I went back like
over summer and like was just working
with them and then started making
records and you kind of just started to
villain like a like a like a friendship
with these guys and so then that's when
they decided that they wanted to assign
me so I ended up signing with them
February 4018 yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
how has it been since then like working
with like freaking sick I meet a lot of
cool people I thought you know she is
about to meet a lot come on cuz it's
crazy too because even just I mean I
guess like for me I mean for you you
were writing your own music what like in
your room or way in my room yeah so like
when I was 16 I started busking at the
Santa Monica promenade and every weekend
my parents it's from Lodi to here is
like a five hour five and a half hour
drive so my parents would drive me down
to LA we'd stay with my aunt every
weekend and every weekend yeah it's a
crazy [ __ ] love you know they
believed in me so much there and like
they knew I didn't want to get a job or
like so like they're like if you're not
gonna get a job like you got to make
money you got to get some then I'm like
all right well I'm gonna sing the street
like I'm gonna do it every [ __ ]
weekend no yeah like everybody in
broking hours yeah no yeah god they
weren't even just like let's try San
Francisco first and see what happens LA
like they like that's where they knew
like okay like they get like four
players foreigners that like travel to
LA I can get people across like the us
to follow you like even like people in
the industry they can just be walking
down the street and see you and like an
opportunity right there you know so like
that's like that's that was my kind of
mindset but I just wanted to sing for
people so like I would get like $300
like a weekend and I was just racking up
and then with that money
I like invested in getting like a home
like recording studio so I would just
record my vocals I got Pro Tools like I
got we used to perform at the Santa
Monica like promenade yeah yeah
yes on Third Street what the [ __ ] yeah
I didn't what the [ __ ] that's so crazy
it's crazy that your parents with that
support I'm not used to that I'm an
Asian American so I'm used to parents
tell you you can't do [ __ ] you know what
I mean unless of stuff that you know
they want you to do right right you're
just so [ __ ] so they believe in your
[ __ ] music they drove you here just
so you can make some cash on the side
and then you just built your own that's
[ __ ] insanity
yeah so I just like with their help like
I they just help me like I just invested
in my yeah so how did you learn how to
do all that stuff they use self-taught
yeah self-taught yeah so like guitar I'm
bringing it back to Justin Bieber um by
the way bro I was just kidding if I ever
see you in person I'm gonna give you a
hug if you allow the truth I'm [ __ ]
around man I'm just [ __ ] around see
that I burned bridges and I build them
back continue all right um listen I
started playing guitar first before
singing I was ten years old this is when
Justin Bieber was starting to come up on
YouTube and I had a lot of time like on
my hands so I was watching YouTube
videos of him playing guitar and singing
like just doing covers like right in the
beginning of his career and um I had a
guitar but I didn't know how to play it
so I was just like okay this gets
playing guitar let me see I can go do it
so I just grabbed my guitar and I was
like alright let me figure this out so
like I paused the video and I'd watch
his fingers and I think obvious fingers
copied the strumming all right oh he's
playing something different
posit would copy his fingers again and
so like it was just like a basic four
chords over and over and over again yeah
and so I was like okay like I got that
down like let me click on other video so
close another video learned a different
song and so I was okay like this is dope
I was like I'm doing something with this
yeah and so it was one day my dad came
home from work and he seen me playing
and he was like wait destiny like what's
going on here and I'm like dad like
listen like I just learned this and I'm
playing it for him and he's like do you
know what you're playing and I was like
not really I was like oh he got back
[ __ ] knob but he was like now I don't
know I'm just copying what this kids
doing on the Internet
and he was like all right we'll come
here so he took me to his piano he was
like alright strum that chord and he I
would strum it and then he was like are
decid e that's a a that's a G and so
like once he would tell me like all the
chords it stuck to my head right away
and then I just was it became addicting
after that so I wanted to learn so many
more songs and then that's when I got
into piano - and this one stuff I self
taught myself on piano and how old were
you just 10 dude like I was I was a
homeschooled in sixth grade so like I
was just doing all that like little
homeschool yeah it was independent study
so I went to school like like three
times a week yeah but like I still had a
lot of time on my hands I like finish my
homework hella early like every day and
then I would just work on it like all
day so I had a lot of time but uhm but
yeah it's pretty much how it went down
and then I just just started singing
like I just started singing so your
parents never brought up the music thing
to you you just started doing that on
your own
my dad kind of threw it in there my dad
would buy me drum sets like every year
for Christmas and so I know how to play
drums too so I gotta play drums you
[ __ ] Prince and [ __ ] just like drop
this [ __ ] like it's all casual [ __ ] it's
like yeah do I know how to do master
instead she just started taking my
pillow and start making a crane out by
the way I also do this because I do okay
but my dad has always taught me like the
basic 1 2 3
yeah like taught me how to count on B
and stuff like that but my dad was my
parents were never the type of parents
to shove something down my throat so
like my parents bought me a guitar and I
wasn't interested and I just like I was
like no I don't think I want to play it
but um but they're like okay like you
don't have to like it's right there you
want it yeah what kind of lifestyle is
this is amazing it was really just a
random day I just was just like no play
guitar today just gonna figure and then
it was an instant an instant love like I
was like okay this is crazy like I just
got mad inspired I was just like you
know like nothing has ever hit me this
hard before then from the moment that
you started playing like 40,000
instruments
then you started when did you start
singing I said no I started singing like
around the same time I learned guitar
like I just started singing like I just
started singing and then my dad like
kind of like noticed that I was getting
like kind of a little good and so since
he was worshiping it was like no he was
at church she was just like oh so you
could sing no she today I don't know
your dad but assuming he's at UCLA
[ __ ] Chicago I'm only I'm we're in LA
right now so that's the type of like a
Mexican that I'm used to is [ __ ] but
anyways you just saw you sing sing and
play guitar and he was like why don't
you like sing this Sunday like or not
saying but like at least play guitar
like in front the congregation on Sunday
for church and I was like yeah like I
was like yeah I want to do it like
that'd be fun and so you say you won't
even scared then either yeah like that
sounds dope so I did it
and then I said then I was like the
worship leader for my youth group like
when I was like 12 years old and so like
I was doing that picking songs every
week and like I was just leading me my
guitar I had a drummer and a piano
player and so like that was everybody
from a youth group it was just always
Church always Wow Church of music yeah
that's so [ __ ] crazy
once it when did you start writing music
then I was 16 I was 16 my songwriting
Dan they said you nineteen million in
long ago yeah what the [ __ ] was the
first one that you wrote um the first
time I wrote it was actually a song
called I never thought and I posted it I
co-produced it with another producer
from my hometown and we posted it unlike
iTunes and Spotify and stuff co-produced
x16 what the [ __ ] am i no yes you make
me hate my [ __ ] up reading right now
but continue so you co-produced at the
age of [ __ ] 16 your very first time
what was it about it was like it was
about I wrote it about a friendship that
what like a fall out like with one of my
best friends and like we were no longer
friends anymore so I just wrote it about
like like people just turning backs on
you and stuff like I never thought this
would happen are you
still friends till this day no [ __ ]
stupid-ass [ __ ] the [ __ ] guess you
lucked out ho anyways I lie back people
up Sactown homie [ __ ] you so wait what
so that's so interesting I feel like
usually when people write their first
song it's all yet it always has to be
about love or like falling in love but
your [ __ ] was about it was about a
friendship fall out like it was it could
have been about a relationship but like
I wasn't interrelation about that time
so it was about a friendship so like I
wrote like a verse and it was only like
20 seconds I was like I'm gonna record
it and post it on my Twitter and just
ask like my phone had like probably like
500 followers on Twitter I was like I'm
just gonna ask and see if they like it
so I brought it my put my phone in the
corner and I sang it along with this
beat that I found it was it was a beat
that I found on YouTube and we couldn't
use it so I had my homie I'm like yo can
we like reproduce this out and then like
yes we like reproduce the beat umm what
made it obviously really different but
um I put the video up on Twitter and I
was like some I'm working on let me know
what you guys think ends up blowing up
so that like added like extra motivation
extra confidence to finish the songs a
basically blown up house just like on
Twitter like I got hella clout like
people retweet in it commenting on it
saying like yo finish this is his fire
did it it it uh and I was like okay they
like it they like it I was like I got to
do it so I ended up just rewriting or
writing the whole thing and I just is
that [ __ ] out for people to hear right
now it was about a year ago but well we
took it down but it's like a fans like
took the audio from it and like put it
on YouTube so like it's on YouTube of
course that was like your baby things
popped you all know yeah that was my
first single like that I've ever like
released like independently
that's [ __ ] yeah how did that feel it
was freaking sick I think it was dope
like I just performed cover songs like
only like when I do like just like open
mics and stuff but like I had that one
song I was like alright and for this
last song it's my own I was like so I
just did it I released an acoustic
version for it too that's [ __ ] crazy
you know what's so refreshing about you
I think like once you I mean as you get
older you tend people tend to get worn
out
life right but whenever I see a young
person talk about like how they came up
which freak wasn't even that long ago
literally your [ __ ] fetus to me you
just you were just made and then like
watching you and just how you speak
about your personal story it's very
[ __ ] refreshing thank you because I'm
in an industry right now we're you know
people they kind of forget where they
started from and how fortunate the
things that they get to do now are right
so they there's a lot of complaints
right so like people my age like you
know in their give 31:32 they they see
all this stuff that they have but they
kind of take you for granted a lot
because they don't realize where they
came from
right so they maybe there's a musician
who started off as like there was a time
when nobody [ __ ] with you right
literally nobody [ __ ] with you I mean
you would make music as much you want
but not a single person would listen but
now sometimes you we kind of get used to
our own success that we kind of forget
to take a step back and be like you know
look at all the [ __ ] that I have yes how
does it feel for you it's just it's
really really dope just cuz you know I
come from Lodi and like when I started
doing music everyone like I would just
post YouTube videos and on Facebook I
liked videos on Facebook too and
everyone was just like oh my god like
there's like a girl that sings like in
Lodi did at us so like the fact that I'm
able to actually it took a long time to
like get to where I am now obviously but
like the fact that like everything is
like like the sex show I had like hello
people from Lodi show up and like it's
just cool that I get to put my city on
the map even if like the world doesn't
know what Laura is like I got to fill my
first like actual like single single and
video in my hometown and like the fact
that it reached like out of the US like
Japan and China like so many people are
repost like posting it out there I'm
just like wow like my town is making it
like outside yeah what I said about Lodi
earlier I'm just kidding I love Laura no
Laura is cute like if you just want to
go for a day yeah if you hate right guy
just - that's where your apples come
from [ __ ] think about that yeah yeah
it's it's good not as cool just because
like we go to New York a lot and
sometimes I'm look on the menu like
there's like Lodi wine on the moon New
York and I'm like yo that's my wine
that's
I know that's like that's like that like
hometown love right yes my friends don't
understand they go low are you buggin
like rep Sacramento so much yeah in town
yeah I think like small town people
really appreciate where they come from a
lot I definitely do like it definitely
just like it built me and coming from a
small town definitely like humbles me I
feel like you're like you might be there
super so I don't know I don't know too
many artists they came out of Lodi not
I'm the only one tiny little statue of
you right there with [ __ ] water
coming at the top of your head no like I
want to be that hometown hero like you
probably already are too a lot of young
people though man just yeah you're from
a small town to like you don't see that
a lot so it's hard for you to it's hard
for younger people to envision
themselves in the shoes that they want
to be in because people from their town
haven't done it like mm-hmm
right so it's it's it's inspiring for a
lot of people I think Sacramento has a
has you know it's coming up specifically
with these guys they're judgmental right
yeah and it's it's amazing to see what
they've done like I am when I went to
their studio I was just like damn yeah I
mean it blows my [ __ ] mind like it's
amazing to me just just to see it happen
yeah like even uh we have a friend named
Phil you know he's he's the the leader
of the Jabbawockeez right he's from
Sacramento we went to the same high
school too grew up together and then to
have him walk around and people just
that's so much the recognition but they
respect him in such a high way blows my
[ __ ] mind
mm-hmm right because he's he was an
originator of a certain dance style that
people [ __ ] that [ __ ] with so much and
even for you you might you you're on
that trajectory becoming that iconic in
your hometown yeah that's that must be
so [ __ ] humbling for you know it is
I'm it's just I'm super blessed your
best friend from back in the day you
[ __ ] up good you [ __ ] up you stupid
[ __ ] oh my god dude
you're so [ __ ] dumb man you're so
stupid
that's what you don't burn bridges dude
duh man you could have you could have
been in a music video ho stupid [ __ ]
hate that girl dude I don't even know
why [ __ ] what's her [ __ ] name you're
not gonna say it but I'll say her name
is [ __ ] Nancy [ __ ] Nance No
Esperanza [ __ ]
you Esperanza even Adela - gotta [ __ ]
[ __ ] hate this girl did I hate people
like that man what did you guys have a
falling-out though just curious when why
oh why um how she backstab you it was it
was actually it was church-related
it was because the house of the law no
like this this like kind of cross like
this is this is like kind of serious but
like she didn't support my music because
it wasn't like of the Lord like because
I was doing what I was doing secular
music and like she didn't support that
that's correct you know that's a huge
thing in like certain Christian churches
right it's like if it's not music for
God then it's a music for sin mm-hmm
right which is kind of like that weird
yeah that's why there was like bands
like Creed they were a Christian band
originally and then they started doing
secular music and they blew the [ __ ] up
and there was like whole controversy
yeah like who who's a who's Christian
I'm pretty sure you know Christian but
like does secular music there's this not
look ray look he's a rapper but it's
like a band like they do like I know
which band you're talking about [ __ ]
Switchfoot yeah which is you know for
them too must have been a weird space
for them too because I feel like yeah a
lot of people think that if it's not
music for God then I do I went to a
couple of churches where they didn't
even want you to play drums they didn't
want you to play drums because they said
drums were from the [ __ ] devil really
yeah and I specifically remembered in
the Bible they played drums oh wait why
I don't know people like to make up [ __ ]
about religion just to like I used to be
a part of this I wasn't a part of it I'm
gonna scratch that I was I attended this
group called it's called que si si si so
the original group was called si si si
which is Christian Crusaders for
Christ's right and they had a Korean
branch and I'm talking about like for me
I loves my Jesus my I love Jesus I love
God right but sometimes like with some
of these groups that I went to for like
support they were just a little too
crazy for me like for example when I
went to college though that Casey CC
group the very first day that I walked
in
there was a friend that I had her name
was Ann Marie so ad Marie we were just
chilling out after service a shot to
Emory he probably got a bunch of kids
now but we're we're chillin and then she
just comes up and she kind of leans her
head on me and the guy comes up behind
me like one of the leaders he goes oh
you can't you can't do that yeah and I'm
like what do you mean he's like you guys
can't do that here you know it's like
where what are you talking about I was
he was like it's just not very Christian
like I was like show me in the Bible
where it says that and then we could
have this conversation mm-hmm and he
goes oh you just can't do a house I
didn't ask you that I asked you show me
in the Bible where this isn't okay and
then maybe we can have a discussion you
couldn't really do it sounds like know
that she's just gonna chill resting her
head here and then you can get the [ __ ]
away from me right right but that's just
a lot of Miss sucks because like
sometimes like a small group of people
who are like that kind of misrepresent a
whole you know kind of I mean like for
her what's the whole point of doing that
what did that accomplish for her you
know that's what I kind of wonder right
aside for her and you obviously she was
probably really young right and she was
influenced by maybe not the right people
when it came to that kind of stuff but
it sucks that day with Lew you would
lose a personal relationship over
something that small when it really was
dumb mm-hmm did that hurt you enough to
write a song about it though most
definitely it was just like that was my
best friend I'm just like you really
just can't support me and what I want to
do like what I love to do and what I'm
called to do honestly if I look back at
it if I'm thinking like let's say if I'm
16 and I saw that type of [ __ ] and as an
adult when I look at it now she probably
just I mean I hate to use his word but
she was probably jealous of your time no
every my every person I told the story
to or like bro
she was just jealous yeah because I was
always going to LA like I was always
leaving and like coming back like doing
it's all supportive his [ __ ] [ __ ] no
parents no yeah like and it was just
like it just became too much it when it
was stressing me out it was making
making me question like my faith and I'm
just like God like is this really what
you have called for me to do like maybe
maybe this maybe my friend is like it's
confirmation from God saying like
destiny yeah like that's right she's
right don't do that but I'm like no I'm
just like no this is what I'm called to
do I know it's what I'm called to do and
so
and you wanna get on you'll run into
this as you continue to become more
successful with you a hundred percent
way yeah that a lot of people too they
they only want you to be successful up
to the level that they're successful
mm-hmm because when you start moving
past them yeah they may want to drag you
down because if you're not at my level
then you think that you're better than
me and you'll experience that a lot it
happens all the time I mean you probably
don't have a mouthpiece like me because
you probably a lot nicer but at a
certain point when you get older you'll
get you to start checking these people
because I have a friend too when I go
back to Sacramento well he doesn't talk
to me now
obviously but every time I would go back
he would be like oh what's up mr.
superstars back in town and you know you
kind of I kind of just let it go a few
times and I'm like ah whatever he's just
jokin issue yeah and then met him up
again he goes aw what's going on big
shot like you hear for the little people
and I just took him aside and I was like
bro are you [ __ ] dumb what's wrong
with you
right and I was like when you got your
new job I congratulated you I said yo
great [ __ ] but every time I come back
you come back well this is sarcastic
[ __ ] yeah what you'll probably
experience that a lot
ya know do you experience that now yeah
yeah like like for the sack show a few
of my homies from from Lodi like from at
my elementary school like showed up to
the show and I'm and now and like and
seeing them I was like hold cuz I'm not
sure what they think of me because like
they don't really talk to me I feel like
I hope that you guys are best friends
that's what they're telling everybody in
the hometown they're like you being
destiny we go way back we should sell
[ __ ] juice boxes together I'd drink
out of a straw give it to her and then
we get the cold together it was insane
crazy [ __ ] dude is that y'all remember
back in the day man [ __ ] sandbox with
[ __ ] I dumped it on your head and you're
like don't do it yeah no more like I'm
trying to say is is like I'm not sure
what they think of me cuz like they
don't really talk to me anymore I don't
know like they don't really talk to me
like I just think they think obviously
that I'm in the music industry and like
I'm coming up so I don't know if that
like makes them nervous like nervous to
talk to me and it's like yo I'm the same
girl yo I'm just like I'm just like we
all go to in and out kick it in the
parking lot let's go like I'm the same
chick dude it's just this is my
my job and this is you know I do this
every day small-town people - it's
intimidating though it is intimidating
and like I I do I like that's the last
thing I want them to feel with me cuz
like I'm so like I don't know I'm just
so loving it's just like I don't want
you guys I mean I know that from you but
people just they're just intimidate you
let me tell you some [ __ ] about this
though like a kid they had John and the
stereotypes everybody John Jeremy [ __ ]
right y'all had a show and you [ __ ] I
forgot where it was but Tatyana Ali was
there and then let me tell you something
that [ __ ] did you think people are just
normal people but when you see people
that you really like [ __ ] with and look
up to it [ __ ] just goes haywire I [ __ ]
shook her head I held that [ __ ] for like
30 seconds and I should have let go and
I and it [ __ ] haunts my drink it
still this day
it haunts me I was like nice to meet you
and then I just kept holding her hand
and I didn't know why and in my mind I
was like you [ __ ] fat [ __ ] let go of
her hand and I just couldn't do it and
then a medic um he goes like over I'm
like oh I do it's just it's intimidating
sometimes charm with with Tori Kelly I
don't know story that well to say it
charmed by the ways one of the amazing
the guy is like seven foot eight the guy
[ __ ] touches the roof with his chin
he's [ __ ] told us no Tori Kelly's
amazing I [ __ ] love you what the crazy
[ __ ] is like when I met Tori Kelly was
that like this YouTube celebrity soccer
[ __ ] I don't even know who she was
when was that this was years ago this is
before she was a Grammy winner and [ __ ]
and I didn't know who she was I didn't
know anything about her music and then
one of my friends like yo I love Tori
Kelly I was like that girl's [ __ ] cute
house I she's she's super nice is super
sweet locked away and I listened to her
music and I was like [ __ ] I had no idea
who that was and I wish I would have
introduced myself that was like me
what's he you know Tara whack no Oh Tara
black Jesus artist that like I'm I love
completely but like I never I would
always just listen to her music and but
I never really just like look to see
what she looked like and we I one of my
first shows was just in the beginning of
March of this year it was at South by
Southwest in Austin Texas
so we were doing a show together it was
me it was just a bunch of female artists
and tiara whack was like the headliner
so I was like oh like I want to like I
want to I want to meet her today but
like I didn't know what she looked like
so after my set I went backstage and I'm
chilling and she comes up to me and she
shakes me and she goes yo you're fire
and know thank you I'm like thank you so
much I gave her a hug her whenever I
didn't know it was her
she didn't say like oh I'm sure I did it
if she didn't know yeah no but like I
was just like okay yeah thank you so
much data and then in the car driving
back to the hotel um I was like wait I'm
gonna go on her Instagram so I wonder
Instagram and I seen her and I yelled
Tierra was the one that came up and
shook my freaking hand I was like I
didn't even know like I was I wish I
could have told her like oh my god dude
like and your music is so sick like I
love it
are you guys connected now do you guys
know she hits you right back hopefully
bro hopefully cuz that net that bridge
is connected now yeah it's not like if I
saw Dave Chappelle like I could hit him
back up and be like yo Davey you know
but you had that type of clout which is
pretty cool yeah mess I could do that
[ __ ] night it's like hey remember one
time you helped me a [ __ ] I still
remember what you smelled like probably
I say that but yeah she kind of weird
like that though so maybe that'll make
her laugh maybe see there you go well
that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah so what you oh man I think I would
be pretty mortified if that happened me
I think I probably think about that for
the rest of my life no yeah it's kind of
just kills me right now I should be fine
I guarantee you if you just hit her up
she'll hit you back up in like a couple
days and then you guys are gonna work on
some [ __ ] together and make hell else
right because even right now I I tell
everybody me and Tatyana Lee best
friends all the time I'm like scheana I
do we're like we reenact Fresh Prince
all day and then she's just like what
Dobis [ __ ] fly is fun so what's
what's on the horizon for you any new
projects
yeah possible project by the end of the
year another one a possible single
really soon just shows and traveling and
by the way they show me a couple of [ __ ]
couple of [ __ ] you know I'm saying I
could [ __ ] you you're [ __ ] crazy
though cuz he cuz John hit me up on my
Instagram and he just linked me a couple
your [ __ ] who deaf that gives this and
he was like Lodi huh alright guy anyways
where she really from where she really
from but it's it's it's kind of crazy
man like I honestly believe that your
type of talent and your music it's one
of those things that come once in a
lifetime because there's there's a type
of learn talent that a lot of people
have right so but you definitely have
something really special to you thank
you so much and it's it's it's
interesting because we're in this age
where you know Spotify and anybody can
get their music up right so I think that
the the concept and the definition of
talent is very loose now
so because back in the day when YouTube
started literally anybody could get a
million views from seeing whatever and a
lot of those artists that popped off
early on and when that talent pool got
bigger they started to disappear yeah
because they just couldn't keep up and
sometimes I get sad because I people
tell me like yellow this person's vocals
are [ __ ] dope I listen to it I'm like
God why did you send me the [ __ ]
which makes me sad right and I think
that a lot of times it happens has to do
with people sometimes just want to
support other people who aren't as
talented because it makes them feel that
they can do it as well mm-hm
so you know I'm not I'm not really
talking [ __ ] like that but I really kind
of it just it just makes me sad a lot
it's like but you do have like this very
like mature adult like vibe to you
because you're so carefree like how do
you what is it you think it's because
you're from Lodi I don't know I don't
know if it has a part in my oh I don't
know man I don't know you're so like
yeah you [ __ ] dumbasses
you [ __ ] up Esperanza and [ __ ] the
other two hometown [ __ ] I'm you're
serious as banda
I'm your anger translator that's what I
do
all right who else do you want to
[ __ ] who else do you [ __ ] it you
talk about I'll let you know you let me
know right now whoever [ __ ] wrongs
you I'll [ __ ] speak for you I send
them straight to hell on a [ __ ]
speedy ass Japanese bullet train ticket
do the [ __ ] yeah so so you got a
couple of projects coming up are there
any artists that you want to work with
in the future that you're really looking
forward to maybe yeah like definitely
want to get on a club with Billy Billy I
definitely need to collab with my girl
kolani definitely need to collab with
post Malone ooh those moms one of my
faves you know post Malone man I got to
tell you something real quick I used to
[ __ ] hate on this guy when he first
came out only because I just didn't like
the emo rap type of [ __ ] right then I
saw him live and I was like who's that
guy who's that homeless man up there I
mean like that's post below and I was
like damn this guy's [ __ ] good like
he's he's one of those people that I
think then when he first stepped on like
like a part of me who just wanted to
dislike him but then he's undeniable
he's so [ __ ] under night yeah the guy
looks [ __ ] crazy but I think that's
why I like him or no exactly like the
first time I seen him live he performed
it's when he opened for Justin Bieber on
tour when he did purpose so my parents
bought me tickets to like do me angry
trust me we're sorry I met him before
just saying yeah post Malone open for
him and I was just like I already knew
who post was but like I was just like
this is full with like cornrows I'm like
all right cool but like he was mad
Townsend like super talented a super
fresh sound that I haven't heard before
that's what me yeah just like like fall
in love with this guy and his music
like for real I'm a big fan that's crazy
yeah I want you to say it out loud so
you can [ __ ] speak it into existence
I guarantee you it's gonna happen for
you and the next thing you know you're
like dude I'm [ __ ] working with post
Malone dude can't wait it's gonna happen
can't wait it'll be [ __ ] insane he's
such an interesting looking guy I don't
know how he just wakes up looking like
that but you have to try to look that
crazy I'm like I had a bigger of a
mouths like shocked that was like holy
[ __ ] it's like do you mind
one Christian dude named was named David
Crowder yeah oh my god yo you remember
David crowd it was crazy looking for
when I went to a a Christian concert you
know David Crowder
you know David Crowder looks homeless I
[Music]
was at what was I [ __ ] at was it like
SeaWorld or some [ __ ] but either way
they were doing it within a theme park
you might be sure wasn't SeaWorld's
probably like [ __ ] like great great
America or some [ __ ] like that
but he did a concert there and so a
great America it was like within the
theme park Six Flags Great America I
wonder which one but he did a concert
there and then when I went there I saw
this homeless man walk up I've never
seen David Crowder before somebody get
this [ __ ] stage and it was David
Crowder dude David Crowder looks like he
just gave up on life it's crazy then you
start hearing him say I'm like Yoda I
would have never [ __ ] known nobody
would have known I didn't know nobody
[ __ ] told me that [ __ ] but he looks
crazy dude he makes post Malone look
[ __ ] like Shia LaBeouf or some [ __ ]
in the Disney days shout out the Shiloh
even Stevens even Steven I actually love
Shia LaBeouf I just I just talk [ __ ]
just for the [ __ ] of it but Justin
Bieber I [ __ ] love them
Shia LaBeouf I [ __ ] love them and
post my [ __ ] love mm-hmm we love you
guys yeah man if you feel any type of
negative way about that just put it on
me because I'm just saying [ __ ] yeah I'm
not saying anything of course cuz she
[ __ ] loves you I love you guys yeah I
just I just like to say crazy [ __ ] yo
you know what that's really about it
we're pretty much good now we do this in
the 45 minute segment you [ __ ] killed
it is there anything that you want to
put out there like put your tags your
handles new music on the way keep
streaming tom boy EP get them plays
going follow me on instagram and twitter
i'm destinee Rogers YouTube and VEVO I'm
destiny Roger's support your girl wonder
that when did the the tomboy you pee
drop recently right
yeah and end of march right into March
so it's been out for like a few months
before we end though how did that feel
the best crazy yes yeah cuz like I said
I've been working with these guys since
I was 17 so there are some records on
the EP that I've had that we've just
been holding like so they're out now
what
is really cool isn't it so nerve
wrecking though it's like God you have
this [ __ ] that you just want to show the
[ __ ] world
ya know yeah it sucked it really did
suck cuz like I wanted music to come out
like as soon as we started working on
like okay like can we drop this like
they're like no like it's not like we
need to like build you know that's about
music though right there's this if
there's a I want to say there's a
science to it but there's a method to
the madness right yeah it's not just
like dropping things whenever you want
the timing is right you want on the
track with you like it sounds it's crazy
man yeah
damn who the [ __ ] is that postman lone
Bronco one day if you become friends
with post Malone bring him on the
podcast like you'd be down for that dude
I just wanted a sip and a Budweiser I
would just want to cut a piece of his
hair and then frame it on my wall
anymore what he cut it short
am I missing a photo of him in a while
he caught his forget well I'm not sure
if he did I'm pretty sure and his team
told him to do it but the hit the long
hairs gone I like that [ __ ] about me to
rock and roll
what the [ __ ] oh man he got email yeah
yeah oh yeah dude post e man why would
you do that dude me and post e go way
back by the way yes and I mean pull we
back him they reached the post mates
together it was crazy I used to do post
mates yeah I believe it is new post
mates in sac and then I was doing post
mates I had a job at a winery and I was
were gonna Starbucks I was hustling
while I was working with them trying to
make it like I was literally in LA
living my dream and then I came home and
I had to work and do all that stuff is
really what the [ __ ] what the well it is
you do you're only 19 how did you do all
these things did you sleep
yeah I slept I was like you like I don't
like be like the things that you can do
and what you've done within that short
amount of time for me it feels like it
shows that you didn't waste time a lot
no can't like and is just for me it's
just like I don't let a day like I don't
let a day go to waste
it's just like I just want to be busy
where the [ __ ] do you find her bro like
when I have a kid this is this is what I
want most likely won't turn out this way
though but most likely for sure because
it has my blood in it but that's [ __ ]
crazy
well you you like I said that's such
that's like things that adults can't do
right now they don't understand how
precious time is because my [ __ ] now is
that you never get time back hmm
time wasted is something that you will
never ever get back and just for a lot
of people that [ __ ] doesn't really sink
in with them is crazy that a
nineteen-year all the same yeah I think
it's cuz my mom my mom is very
hard-working so she's always instilled
like that were that ethic with me and my
sister so like my sister is such a hard
worker and like it just just came to me
and so I'm just like every all of my
family is all of my family on my mom's
side is very hard-working
so it was like it's like in the blood so
looks like a regular day for you that I
was supposed to end this pocket by
minding it I was like a regular day for
you out here it kind of depends like I
have a schedule but it's not like too
crazy yet so like I probably have like
one thing a day like today this is the
only thing I had to do today but like in
the morning like I live by myself so
like I wake up ie there's a gym so I go
work out and then I'll come back shower
get ready and then I'll just probably
just I don't have a lot of friends out
here but I'll probably just like go kick
it somewhere how fun a spot to go kick
it well you you I mean how long have you
been out here uh since January beginning
obviously you just started them
yeah I'm just yeah yeah I feel like most
people in the city though they're not
really from here though so you're not
you're not you're not something that
everybody like that nobody is [ __ ]
from here yeah how many anybody is like
everybody in a boobie the premier you
know Jane yeah that's crazy is that kind
of hard is that kind of hard for you
though living by myself and stuff yeah
cuz you're kind of I mean I know you
have your uncle you know couple of
cousins but yeah I definitely think it I
mean I've been working at this for a
long time and my parents and my family
knew like okay eventually destiny is
gonna need to move out and move to LA
and do her thing
so like when it happened like as the
process like when I got like like when
my apartment got confirmed and like okay
like my moving day is this date cool
like doing this didn't know we moved we
did all that but then it was until I was
in
my apartment by myself and I'm looking
around I'm like a kid this is my house
like this is where I'm gonna live like
this is where I'm gonna cook this is
where I'm gonna shower like it's my crib
and it like it's crazy because like it's
just me and my mom that lived together
like my parents split up when I was
young and so they my it was just me my
mom that lived together like my sister's
a lot older than me she has kids so she
and her family lived together by herself
by themselves so it's just me and my mom
and so like having to get up and move
and I my mom was by herself so it's just
like that was that was like another
piece that was very hard to cope with oh
yeah for sure yeah so like so you're
really close with your mom then yeah for
sure like I'm I'm definitely close with
both of my parents yeah but I chose to
live with my mom Oh what made you want
to choose live with your mom I just
think cuz it's my mom it's like mmm like
that motherly instinct like I'm a
daddy's girl for sure like that's my
dad's my boy yeah like my mom like I
just like she's sweet she's humble she
plays 12 instruments what'd you do like
b-boy and [ __ ] - what else to do like
the [ __ ] oh you skateboard as well oh
boy yeah well just [ __ ] cry how'd you
get into that I got into skateboarding
when I was like I was six or something
like that like we lived by a skate park
and there was like skaters I would
always skate by my house and I would
always just sit by the window and just
watch them skate by and I always wanted
a skateboard but like when I was young
like my mom never really bought me a
skateboard cuz she it was just like
really strict she's like I don't want
you getting hurt that it up so at family
functions my cousin was skate and my
cousin had a board and would bring I'd
always tell I'd always tell him like yo
Eric like can you bring that board with
you to the two grandmas later and he was
like oh yeah I got you
and so he drained the board and I would
skate in the front yard with him that
was the only time I was ever able to
skate because my parents and inviting me
aboard so finally one year for my
birthday I was it was my eighth birthday
my grandparents from my dad's side
bought me a skateboard I was like all
right I was like like for show like
let's go skate and so I was like dad
it's like take me to the skate park and
he's like all right so after work he
would take me to skate park like every
day and I literally just like learned
how to skate by myself and then I
started
like surrounding myself with skaters
that were better than me at the park and
so I would just like they would teach me
how to do like tricks and all that well
how good are you asking though
that's the question like can you you can
Ollie you can kick a flip like hang on
all these stairs and hit rails hit
ledges and and all that but like I'm
able to like if I wasn't to kick it with
pros I'd be able to keep up with keep up
with them a little bit but like I'm not
gonna be doing some crazy crazy like I'm
not like a professional status like I
could have gotten there if I took it
serious like I wanted to get there like
that because that was before like I got
into music was one because I started
skating before I got into me probably
would have killed him that too I
probably I was on my way there dude like
I literally was like okay skating
skating's it's my passion woman's ex
games like this is what I'm gonna do
this in my life but the music hit
different look at you just so
multifaceted disgusting yes no but I
still do it though like I became friends
with like one of my homegirls in the the
tomboy music video and murderin like
she's like one of my good friends so
like we kick it sometimes when she's in
LA and then I made a couple more like
skater friends in LA that are girls so
it's cool getting scared the [ __ ] out I
mean I used to do that [ __ ] when I was
super young but then it just I just
thought of look funny when in fact I was
on skateboard so I was like it just
looks like that bad [ __ ] boards are
there a lot of stress like damn I feel
bad for that board all the birds are
snapping the two pieces of [ __ ] oh man
it's Kerry was like skating was so scary
like I remember when all my friends
would do it like I like I tried it and I
just like damn I don't know about this
[ __ ] dude it's so [ __ ] frightening me
but you you fine with it
yeah it's just it was cool can you skate
you play the drums guitar piano you're
seeing your write your own music what
else do you do destiny oh yeah I play
bass no but what else do I do
nothing much I just think yeah I don't
really do anything else and you got that
[ __ ] Aliotti on look at ya my boy
poon she actually did this and you got a
friend named punchy that's crazy yeah
punchy shout-out punchy for the one time
what the [ __ ] that his real name it's
not his real name but that's his like
because he he punchy
this fool he's from Stockton so he does
a lot of stuff like he's a tattoo artist
he does heart work he does shirts like
this
crazy so he hooked it up with a shirt
and then I was like punching sound like
I'm stalking you guys don't know where
Stockton at Stockton like Modesto area
I like Stockton people but some of you
guys are unruly human beings ghetto
people white ghetto we don't want to say
that so I will they know it's not my
people from Stockton like nah we're fine
no it's literally so funny cuz like
there's always like some people that
like hate on me reppin Lodi like I get
like kids not well probably kids do you
mean me saying why are you supporting
your crackhead town and I'm like okay
listen we do have a few Tweaker do not
talk about my city like there's a farm
town I do something [ __ ] no there's
nothing to do some drugs no but that's
so funny to cos like Stocki I'm saying
like like hometown love when people love
their small little hometown they [ __ ]
love it though my Stockton people rep
stocked in to the day I have a friend
named Lin she calls herself stock a Lin
we call it Glock dude dude doctors
[ __ ] ghetto like the Modesto area
[ __ ] too cuz I used to hang out there
when I was a kid a lot but those were
not very nice people I used to hang out
with but you know it's people rep their
[ __ ] men like Stockton so [ __ ] ghetto
to me like people go people from
Stockton vacation in Sacramento vacation
a Sacramento swag mid-tone popping man
yeah dude I would just I would just go
to Arden Fair Mall Danny I'll just go
there now that shit's [ __ ] ghetto man
no yeah I'd go to art in and then I go
to go to the Guitar Center right there
and then I go to chick flavor it in
there and then on the way home hit Dutch
rosanell Grove that's [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was my thing like every Friday night yes
so Dutch Bros is like maybe like seven
minutes away from my house diet - Rose
is so good I need one in LA like I
actually need one so she needs to open
up a Dutch Bros in LA that's number one
crazy hell out here though no wood it
would roll there's so many people not
what I'm saying is that you like dutch
bros because of nostalgia and that's
what you [ __ ] with like the level of
first of all I like this well yeah
because actually LA has like a lot of
like like Dutch coffee shop yeah like
Dutch pros would not survive out here
yeah actually
I'm thinking about it I don't think no
one would like it yeah there's nothing
that you're not good at Bizness [ __ ]
that [ __ ] in your face business oh yeah
you you got too many talents anyways but
yeah that is this podcast today man I
got to tell you it's you are you are
refreshing to be around young lady thank
you so much I just got like this soul
sunshine thing about you like it's
almost it's like Daddy I'm like trying
to hate you but it's so [ __ ] hard I
got water aged you but I can't that's
crazy but once again check her out you
know she got some new [ __ ] coming I'm
telling you right now if you you guys
better be the type of people that acted
like you knew about it before she
[ __ ] blew up even bigger that's
that's how dope she's gonna be you guys
can check out genius brain on Spotify
iTunes everywhere else if you see us
give us a five star in the comments
below give us a thumbs up make sure that
you follow her see her journey because I
guarantee you you're gonna feel like
you're missing out in your [ __ ] face
and by the way Esperanza I hate your
[ __ ] guts amen
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]